I love you I love you Isis you want a
healthy I'm hopeful vice with Bobby
kalila and mo Collins hi right nice
voice I'm between your old male from
Poland and I've got a problem I've never
really had friends or been in a
relationship and is it affected the way
I perceive stuff especially with women
every time I'm talking with a girl I'm
thinking about her in a romantic way
whether it's a friend asked me about
school a girl I don't know who hits me
up because she wants to buy books I even
at work there's a language barrier even
have a random stranger on the internet I
don't act I just a dream
I don't want stuff like that to distract
me and I know I'm putting others before
myself for example could talk with such
girls knowing I've gotten something else
to do but the craving for the feelings
is stronger how I quit this virgin like
attitude where I see all women in a
romantic way I especially want to stop
doing that because I'm moving to study
at university very soon and I want to be
free there big fan of the podcast is
never free a Greg yeah good I mean
that's just it's it's heartbreaking that
that's a problem for him and it because
it's really it's just that's his heart
mm-hmm growing every time he talks to a
woman the way he says that he's not even
like thinking of the maliciously he's
daydreaming of romance oh my gosh
it's need he needs aroma he needs a
girlfriend he needs a place to put this
yeah he wants to love he wants love but
so I missed those aching she's shaking
she's right here she's right here but
what I'm saying is that I mean that
that's you're young you just hurt my
feelings
she is right you know yeah yeah the
aching the aching yeah I used when I got
together with my um my now husband we
used to call it chunking that feeling
when you would get together and it would
tingle and it just goes shunk right down
to your sex bits
yeah where the blood just shunts yeah
it's like we know region or hear them or
they do something they look at you a
certain way and just chunk right down my
fifth album like so many so overwhelming
yeah that's an amazing amazing feeling
but I adult love might feel like
chunking on occasion but set puppy love
that high school feeling of that aching
that you're talking about that's what
I'm talking about where you can't quite
get there with a one that you have the
biggest crush on and it's soul-crushing
yeah I would like walk a dream yeah like
in the suburbs I have no car really you
know I have no I don't know what I want
to do with my life
it's it's the late eighties right it's
summer and then you see a girl riding on
her bike I mean even a Jew to be a
Jewish girl I'm a white lady yeah to be
a Jew and she's like truck riding her
sure in your heart you know there's
Larisa Feingold I don't see the last
part but I think it's Larissa I think
it's important for us though to those
moments yeah you have to because they
don't come the same way yeah as we are
older yeah yeah you have to create them
yeah yeah
romance is available to all of us you
have to create it I think that's what we
probably lack talk about later we forget
to date each other
yeah it's like I love periodically even
just throwing on the song from our
wedding and dancing and staring into my
my husband slash lovers eyes
two days ago he did say what at 9:00
a.m. he was still awake and he and we
were driving back from Koreatown he's
like you know he at 9:00 a.m. I was
still awake this morning and I listened
to this song and I
cried and I thought wow like he really
is thinking about me because I'm
sleeping in the bed next to him and I
was worried crying about he was I was
thinking about you dying and I know that
sounds kind of weird but I was like wow
that's actually really well hey if
that's what it takes to take it but
truly it's like you think we do take
it's too easy to take advantage of the
people we love the most you know but
it's like if that's what it takes to get
you to a feeling yeah think about the
person you cuz look life is fleeting
this [ __ ] could be over in an hour
do you know what I mean and so recognize
that we were not gifted tomorrow
automatic it's like that
Oh think about think about it how much
they mean to you and your everyday you
don't want to be without that person so
while we're here do the things look at
look at each other and recognize that
and say those things to each other soon
after that though he loved you so much
but after that happened I was like oh
that's really sweet music that was the
first time that I ever I said this I
said hold on let me say this is the that
you said that this is the first time
that I ever felt sad about the idea of
you dying I was like so that's not one
of three days ago you weren't I could
have died and you would have felt
nothing he was like yeah this is
probably the first time I felt that I
was like six years in no what I said was
this and that's ridiculous because what
I said was this okay
was it that I have thought about you
know the only people in my life if I
close my eyes or I'm sleeping or at mid
sleep and I thought if they died it was
my parents and my brother that would
have been devastating I would wake up
from that sleep and not be able to see
she's the first girlfriend where if I
when I have thought that and thought oh
the same as I would as my brother I'm
yeah do you know just what I'm saying or
no yeah like she was like like she's
beyond now you know I mean just some you
know hoochie-coochie with you
I'm telling you everything up until that
morning I was just a hoochie but that
morning is what yeah like yeah like a
couple of months ago they've been like
let me see your holes is that the next
album let me see your whole wheat holes
it's like what yeah your meat holes you
know men love that romantic and I just
ready to open I go yes bid on it
oh but now it's like oh no my meat hole
don't die that's another one no that's
his t-shirt oh that's sweet hold a
[Music]
website I in college millimeter holes
calm really wow that was a thing and it
used to be like prolapsed anus and God
you were so behind on the porn bag
coffee are you for your mind of course
it's how I said meet holes
okay good as long as you know the
website we're on yeah yeah the best do
you think all of this helped that guy in
Poland bet if I'm a meatball
[Music]